foreign
[Music]
spoilers show I'm your host Paul aka the
guy who always comes through with a
breakdown in the Rick of time in this
video we're going over the latest
episode of Rick and Morty the new entry
is filled with Easter eggs lots of
hidden details and also some callbacks
to earlier entries in the show now the
episode is called Final Destination
which took me about 20 girls to get
right and this Jerry and Rick theme
centered entry has a lot going on with
it obviously the tunnel refers to the
Final Destination film franchise in
which characters are cheated death were
slowly taken out by a one by one the
franchise was all about trying to change
your future or in this case your fortune
the entry is very fortune cookie based
and it has a company in it called
Fortune 500 which is an annual list
published by Fortune magazine that
documents a top 500 corporations now we
start off at a Panda Express with the
Smith Sanchez family just having some
delicious before you say that sounded
racist you can ask the waiter how they
say it we also hear that Morty and
summer have changed Rick's ringtone to
the Taxi theme due to it trending on
tick tock they say it slaps it hey
[Music]
because it does and this is actually
used as the music that goes over the
credits at the end as well as the
shootout scene in the Panda Express at
this point we watch Rick use Dr Octopus
arms which [ __ ] out of his back rather
than using Chopstick so he just ends up
using two forks showing how he doesn't
really care about the culture now at
this point they get given some fortune
cookies which we later learn are
actually made from Alien poop The
Fortune 500 company actually used a
creature who has the power to turn
entropy into fate it takes chaos from
the universe and digests it pulling in
the unknown towards the known the end
results of this lead to the fortunes
inside the cookies being guaranteed and
because of this there's no escaping them
most of them are pretty straightforward
with Beth and Morty's even being the
same both talk about family time and how
its time well spent which ties into them
going to the zoo however this then leads
into the ultimate family time for Jerry
which is of course sex with his mother
Jerry's mum first appeared in anatomy
Park all the way back in season one and
in this episode we see more of her than
I'd like to now from here we go to the
titles however in this video we cut to
the bit where I beg you to hit the
thumbs up button and do a like comment
share subscribe combo so I don't have to
get a proper job after I've done that
bit I'll be hitting you with the jingle
for the heavy spoilers show which goes
like this
[Music]
now the fortune cookie message naturally
Spooks Jerry as he thinks this could be
true certainly things related to his
mother start popping up everywhere and
he begins to worry that his fate is
sealed I thought the toning was
hilarious and the bit with a cupboard
and the big mother was pretty funny in
the end he ends up dressing up as Mori
because he says if he has sex with his
mother then that's gonna be Beth there's
also an interesting picture in the Smith
Sanchez home that I don't think we've
seen before which contains stills from
the first motion picture ever created
this involved a man riding on the back
of a horse and it was referenced heavily
in Jordan peele's no Jerry then asks
them to take photos of the white tiger
which is his favorite animal bethan
replies by saying because they breed via
incest is that true
now this could actually tie back to a
story from a couple of years ago in
which the quote-unquote world's ugliest
tiger was bred in a bit to make money it
came out with a really weird face due to
them in Reading white tigers with each
other which FPL that this is linking
back to after several scientific tests
we're Rick discovers that there's a high
probability that this is a reality in
which he'll have sex with her you get a
literal Dick in a Box test and Rick
carries these out with a device that
looks like a PKA meter these were used
in Ghostbusters and the way the two rods
pop out makes me think that the design
was based on that the pair returned to
the Panda Express and in the back we see
some suspicious members of Staff one has
a tattoo tier another has a scar on his
face and the other is missing an eye in
heavily covered in ink they're packing
up meth and immediately starts shooting
there's a split second shot where the
chef pops up too and whilst the Carnage
ensues Jerry's mum starts texting him
some things that could be misinterpreted
I got lots of Vibes at the end of
Breaking Bad with a ship blasting away
inside the restaurant similar how Walt's
car did when he went to rescue Jesse the
restaurant is of course also a meth rund
similar Helga's star warfing was running
one with Los Pollos Hermanos it's all
just one big misunderstanding though and
they then get given directions to
Fortune 500 I thought the retina scan
was hilarious with spiders also going
over Jerry's eyes like it was something
pulled out of Minority Report at this
point Rick surveills the area using a
mechanical eye that pops out of his head
this is obviously pulling from shows
like Inspector Gadget and we've seen
these devices used on things like
fingers throughout the entire family in
season 3 episode 5 we saw that his other
eye could transform into a Target and a
nice little joke here was that it made
him lose his depth perception anyway the
area is lited with cameras and disabling
all these would draw more attention to
them than just dressing in costume eye
of thundera give me suits Beyond suits
now this is a call back to Thundercats
in which the eye of thundera used to
give sight Beyond sight
[Music]
the eye of
[Music]
eye of humans give me sight Beyond sight
Rick ends up donning his suit and
sunglasses which the character also wore
in the Omaha music video with her in the
jewels great music video and song so
definitely go check it out very good
visuals there's also a clear reference
to Sailor Moon with Jerry's
transformation I love when they do
little nuts to stuff like this and Rick
even says how they can constantly use
this over and over if he ever becomes
his assistant again Sailor Moon
obviously kept reusing animations and
they even end up reusing at the end of
the episode ironically Jerry ends up
wearing his normal clothes anyway so it
was completely pointless in getting
changed in the first place they also
blend into the wall which was used as a
trick that we saw Rick do all the way
back in the decoy episode we can also
see a little cursor appears on this and
this is exactly how the Clone tool
appears when you use Photoshop turns out
there's a massive conference at highly
successful world leaders or an
attendance at Bezos Bill Gates Prime
Ministers weirdly Billy Zane is also
here yeah we meet the CEO who reminded
me a lot of Sharon Stone turns out she
built the company from the ground up and
this happened after an alien crashed
into her backyard she ended up getting a
cookie that said she'd become the most
successful businesswoman on Earth and
Rick ends up helping this happen by
removing trillions of dollars from
Goldman Sachs to buy out the business in
the end he gives us all back but because
the fortune happened it's now null and
void she promises that she can change
your fate if you invest enough and could
be based on Elizabeth Holmes Holmes was
the CEO of a company that claimed to be
able to produce highly accurate blood
tests but these heavily malfunctioned
and didn't do what she claimed in the
end she ended up getting shut down after
receiving hundreds of millions in
Investments and is now seen as a massive
failure due to her lies in the seat now
on the whole these cookies are
impossible to avoid with security guards
kicking the crap out of Rick after
taking them however he realizes that
because Jerry's future hasn't come true
yet that he can use him as a human
shield there's a great little detail on
the scan characters and we can see that
a circle appears which is actually from
a zodiac shot at this point they come
across the fortune Smith and can catch
the creature creating the cookies I feel
like the former is based on the guy from
Waterworld who is forced down into the
oil in the tanker in order to keep an
eye on things the monster itself seems
like it's pulling from God of War 2.
namely the sister of Fate who weaves
together all the threads of someone's
life in order to control their Destiny
and the new fortunes are a bit weird and
it turns out these were sent out as a
cry for help but someone would arrive
and help rescue the pair the Smith sent
out several of these including how a
virus would end up shutting down the
world which the CEO has brought in
Jerry's mother and the guards end up
taking several fortune cookies Rick as
to use his wits to outsmart them all
into killing each other and there are a
couple of nods here and there to some
specific things and there's a part where
someone controls the moisture inside
someone's body I think this is similar
to how the atlanteans and Zack Snyder's
Justice League did it so so someone who
can stick to walls similar to Spider-Man
and a God that also gets immortality
whether this doesn't mean he can't feel
pain any ends up getting shot several
times by a minigun records are finding
several fortune cookies with random
effects and he fires them into people's
mouths one transforms into the Red
Ranger T-Rex that you'll probably
recognize from the Power Rangers if you
are a 90s baby the CEO ends up eating
lots of random cookies after her Fortune
comes true and this transforms her into
a gigantic Resident Evil style monster
the famous stands up going wild and my
man realizes he's romanticized a wild
animal he brings up Margaret Howe and
she participated in nasa-funded research
to see if a dolphin named Peter could
mimic human speech it frequently got
sexual urges and Margaret would choke
the dolphin in order to relieve it and
move on with the lesson in the end Peter
ended up drowning himself because the
spacers didn't have any natural sunlight
and Peter sadly got depressed really
weird story that I definitely recommend
you check out and the dot the guy goes
off on a monologue for a reason that she
might pick your interest now I can't
show this clip because my vids have been
getting demonetized recently but he also
gets ripped apart similar how stara
pulls a thinker upon Suicide Squad the
beast eats the CEO and avoid his crate
which leads to some hilarious stuff that
Jerry and his mother just missing out
Jerry leaves a thank you message for
Rick and then calls him a friend turns
out Rick was Immortal until he made a
new friend and Jerry has now robbed him
of this power the real friends were the
ones we made along the way though and
deep down I do think they like each
other anyway we could of the post
credits sting out which leads us to the
zoo and see people eating zebra food
everyone ends up eating it and it ties
back to the beginning of the episode
when they made fun of Jerry for doing
the same this warning makes Morty super
confused over what to do and he realizes
that it's a human Zoo anyway that ends
the episode and this was another one
that I really enjoyed lots of weird
incest stuff going on this season but
overall I had a good time with it and I
hope you enjoyed the video too we are in
a competition right now giving away
three copies of Dolan and thunder on the
15th of October and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our bright enough House of the
Dragon which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over the entire
thing talked about the book differences
Easter eggs and definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for saying to the video I've been Paul
let's see in the next one take care
peace